welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is pro the doge aka the dogecoin
millionaire and i think that you guys
have made uh
a million dollars wow
we get the wild guess holy cow jeez you
know this should be like the price is
right where if you go over you lose you
went over man i went over it yeah
165
000 is how much we've made so far wow
solid that's still impressive thank you
thank you for those that aren't aware
of you and your story we had you on
gosh almost a year ago yeah but nine
months ago yeah you went all in dogecoin
and you made this big outsized bet that
dogecoin was going to blow up and go up
in price and was going to hit a dollar
and in the span of only a few months
yeah you turned to your life savings you
cashed out of everything you you put
money on credit cards you put everything
into dogecoin you turned that investment
of a few hundred thousand dollars into
as high as almost three million dollars
yeah in three months you were everywhere
cnbc
market watch cnn everybody york times
the new york times
everywhere because you had this story
about going from you know your life
savings yeah which was still substantial
at the time yeah but going all in and uh
and being right and and making a lot of
money
and uh we we talked with you back then
we tried to convince you to sell yeah
didn't want to sell yeah uh then we
covered the update a few months later
after the after saturday night live
premiered and uh dogecoin faltered a bit
on elon musk's remark yeah and but still
hold held up a lot stronger than you
thought it was going to do i agree
but
here's the thing we've missed you on
your channel
yeah
i i
i want you to post on your channel and
it's been over a month now yeah and
people have not heard from you you've
just disappeared so there's some
speculation on what's going on okay but
i wanted to first of all welcome you to
vegas thank you and get the inside scoop
what's been going on over these last few
months what are your thoughts of
dogecoin what are your thoughts on
cryptocurrency what are you doing
just the crypto space in general yeah
took a huge fall right like we're seeing
it happen right now where bitcoins low
ethereum is low like just
crypto's low you know so dogecoin right
along with them is low as well
uh as far as as far as the future of
dogecoin i still i'm super bullish on
dogecoin i still feel like it's gonna do
very well in long term which is how i'm
holding long term and there are a few
things still on the horizon for it that
i feel like are really going to help it
continue to rise you know in the future
so i got like we got the robin hood
wallets situation that i remember
talking to you about i was like look
robin hood holds a third of all the
dogecoin in existence in its own wallets
right
you can't buy anything with anything you
buy
you can't buy anything
with the dogecoin you have in robin hood
so when they release wallets and when
you're able to take your money out then
you can actually use it it'll be in
circulation be able to use it and that
would help you know rise the price of
dogecoin as well that's one of the
things another one is
i mean there's a mission to the moon and
elon musk like a literal mission to the
moon and elon musk has spacex
completely funded by dogecoin
and the name of the rocket is doge1 and
it's going to the moon and they're
putting a dogecoin in the rocket no in
fairness i'm a huge fan of elon musk he
does say a lot of stuff though he does
and there's some stuff that he says and
then he keeps pushing it off the tesla
roadster is a perfect example and i was
a little bit upset when he said we're
not getting a cyber truck this year
we're not getting a roadster this year
and instead of just acknowledging hey
you know we just have other you know
priorities right now it's like hey let's
look at this robot over here we're
coming out this new robot
in my opinion it's almost like hey let's
let's hide this but uh here's a robot
yeah it's like if you're trying to hide
a toy from a dog you're like yeah here's
this toy over here
oh that toy truck i feel like he's kind
of doing that with with everybody true
so i mean i get that the doge won i'm
not sure if that
what if that doesn't happen
i mean there's also there's always a
possibility that things don't go
according to plan and some things happen
and you know that that's more of a
marketing thing more of like an
awareness thing like those will be on
the headlines again and all that um as
far as the robin hood wallet situation
that's more of like a actual real world
use case for dogecoin so that's more
water don't you think that would lower
the price though because right now
people are holding on to it so they're
taking dogecoin out of circulation yes
driving up demand because they're
holding on to it but if you're able to
use dogecoin as a currency yeah all of a
sudden i'm paying jack
uh for you know what he earns in
dogecoin jack's not going to then pay
his groceries in dogecoin he's going to
sell the dogecoin and then get cash for
it so even though i'm able to transact
the the other person isn't going to hold
dogecoin they got to pay their taxes
they they got expenses they got bills to
pay
wouldn't they just cash that out to you
to usd
i mean it depends right if i feel like
if you find value in dollars coin you
want to hold dogecoin i feel like those
people are always going to have those
coins right if you want to buy sell
trade what have you obviously robin had
opened up opening up wallets is gonna
add to that and help that out but when
people wanna go buy things like
groceries or things of that nature
i feel like mass adoption is still gonna
happen over time and one day we'll be
able to do that you know but
let's say you have a card right let's
say you have a visa card and you can put
dogecoin in the card and anywhere that
visa is accepted you can actually use it
to be able to buy whatever you want do
you think that adds value to dogecoin no
because
you're buying dogecoin to put on the car
to spend money in dogecoin so it's like
you're you're making it complicated it's
like if you're taking usd and the end
goal is to buy a product you wouldn't
buy dogecoin to then spend the dogecoin
on the card you just spend money on the
card and spend it with cash
well well the thing is this
some people are scared of buying
dogecoin right yeah but if you were to
use a car to be able to use it in cash
and get dogecoin rewards back you're
holding those coins in a sense right i
do think that the net change of
something like that would probably just
be more people holding dogecoin like
sure yeah if you get paid in dogecoin
you'll probably sell to convert to usd
but at the same time there will be
people that don't sell inevitably it's
not like every single person immediately
as they get the dogecoin is gonna sell
some will hold for a little bit some
will hold for a while yeah and yeah but
surely yeah some will convert to usd i
don't know i i still feel like those
coins are good form of currency i feel
like it can still be used in a
day-to-day basis over time yeah and and
i feel like eventually that will rise
even if it's slowly slowly you know and
just checking you're still holding all
of your dogecoin i am so everything in
robin hood that i bought i still have
i've obviously bought dips and what have
you
you know over the months and stuff like
that i've traded those out and i've
bought other i actually hold a lot of
different coins as well now it's not
just those coins you know what would
have been well i was about to say you
could have
structured it in such a way where you
tried to tax loss harvest but i realized
that a lot
well you would have been able to have
done that a little bit yeah
did you do any of that or no
no okay
[Laughter]
so how much dogecoin is it that you
currently have about four million right
now and um
and i want i want to you know get that
up i want to continue to buy dogecoin as
i go especially now when it's really low
and i want to get you know at least five
million dogecoin at one point and just
kind of hold on to that that was
actually my very first goal when i first
bought into those games i want at least
five million because i feel like it's
easier to do the math there if it goes
to a dollar it goes to two dollars or
what have you but um but i have a lot
i'm very excited about different
projects as well you know dogecoin was
like kind of
my entryway into the crypto space into
the crypto world and now i'm just like
wow
there's this project wow this project
like you know and i'm kind of dabbling
in different projects and seeing other
things do you worry though that if
dogecoin doesn't go up or something
doesn't happen the dogecoin that like
even now
is there any bit of you that would still
want to sell some of it and just
diversify and
i feel like
you mean sell my original yeah amount
see it's it's weird i i feel like that's
kind of locked in for me in a way i feel
like all right i bought that much
dogecoin you know what that's what i'm
holding that kind of because it's weird
man like i feel like
that kind of
is what
got me to where i am today and and you
know i feel like i i kind of owe it to
the dogecoin community too to continue
to hold and continue to die my hand and
continue to believe in dogecoin and so i
feel like my original amount that i
bought into is gonna remain that and i'm
going to stay locked into that and
whatever i make you know from now on or
since i did that i'll be able to buy
other buy into other projects look at
other coins you know i was looking into
cardano i was looking at other utility
coins as well to see what you know
sparks my interest and kind of do a
little you know more digging into those
yeah why haven't you posted over the
last month
there's been a lot of things man there's
been a lot of things so i don't know if
you guys know this but i had kidney
stones for wow yeah i heard that's
extremely painful it's painful man yeah
it's it's like hunched over like oh my
pain and when i first didn't know what
it was i thought i was dying i was like
what's going on my body like
how do you first know about that or how
did you do it
it was it was a pain it was just a like
like
if okay i went to sleep
and it felt like
a constant like stabbing sensation on
the side of your like ribs or something
like and i was just i woke up in the
middle of the night and i was like oh my
god like what's like what is going on
and just went to the hospital emergency
room and they you know they ran the
whole the test and everything did a cats
can and stuff they're like yo
you got a kidney stone man and it's a
big one and i'm like damn like what do i
do like so you know they said just drink
a bunch of water you know
just
it'll go away over time that hurt for a
while i was you know a few weeks
after that i got covered like back to
back right so i got covered when i went
home for the holidays yeah um my last i
think my last video was uh right before
i got coveted i put out a video it was
either around christmas time and then
bam i got hit with covid and i was out
for like two weeks and i was still back
home in maryland and then i came back
here and
it's funny because this happened to me
and i was doing research on it so
apparently a lot of people that have
covet or get covered
right at the tail end they'll get hives
because their immune system is shot shot
you know what i mean so i i got coveted
and then i got hives right after where'd
you get the hives it was just my full
body it was a full body just just
itching i was getting like these red
circles it was just like what is going
on with me yeah and it was like that for
a whole week to the point where
if you guys have never gotten this when
you go to sleep you can't sleep because
you're itching your whole body is just
itching all the time so you can't even
go to sleep and then like i had like i
said i had that for a week and then i
finally finished doing that and then you
know we were shooting with the
documentary right after that i had to
get a negative cova test so i went and
got that and then we were shooting for
about a week or two like every single
day for hours because we had to wrap up
the shooting and everything so all of
like these things have just been
happening back the back the back the
back-to-back up until a week ago so so
many so many topics to talk about one
last thing one last thing one last thing
i'm moving to vegas but first we want to
thank our sponsor grammarly you know
what jack my new year's resolution is to
write a book alex it's february you
should have decided that over a month
ago quiet down jack besides 2022 still
feels new to me because of how busy i've
been and you know what you're not
getting a signed copy anymore well alex
if you're looking to save some time you
should try grammarly premium grammarly
is a writing tool that helps me get the
words right even when i'm short on time
alex how's business lately jack
business is booming and because of that
i've had a lot of emails to get back to
lately but since we installed grammarly
on our computers we've been able to get
so much of that time back grammarly has
been like having a professional writer
on your shoulder whispering all the
right words with real-time feedback
grammarly premium offers clarity
suggestions and even full sentence
rewrites to help you clearly convey your
message and avoid miscommunication
applying for a job and want to sound
confident well even if you're as
insecure as i am you can use grammarly's
tone detector to ensure that your words
come across as confidently and concisely
as you need so get through those emails
and your work quicker by keeping it
confident concise and effective with
grammarly premium so go to grammarly.com
iced coffee today to sign up for a free
account and when you're ready to upgrade
to gramerly premium you can get 20 off
just because you're a listener that's
grammarly g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee for 20 off
grammarly premium thank you so much
grammarly and back to the podcast yes so
i've been looking at places we got a lot
we got a lot to break down here so for
the kidney stones i remember seeing a
picture i think somebody posted this on
reddit
breaking down a kidney stone under a
microscope and this is the scariest
thing to look at because it looks like
this spiked ball yeah you know like it
looks like ball and glass
yeah like imagine like a shard of glass
but with edges that come out like like
this yeah and like that's got to pass
through you on the inside just kind of
like
tearing stuff up along did it get
dissolved or did it like so it's
supposed to so basically
um a company actually i posted on
twitter that i had kidney stones i was
like sorry guys i got kidney stones and
then and then a company reached out to
me and was like hey these pills help
it's like a herbal way
it's called chancapeda or something like
that but it basically helps to break
down that kidney stone and then it's
supposed to just be like sand
and then you're supposed to just pee it
out
how do you get kidney stones or is that
hereditary yeah okay so here's the crazy
part i wasn't even surprised when they
said i got kidney stones because the
very first time i had kidney stones i
was 22 23. wow so it wasn't like an a it
wasn't like a maybe food or whatever
later i'm sure things you know play a
role but it's definitely hereditary and
i remember growing up and after i forgot
my first kidney so i was like i'm so
young why am i getting kidney stones and
i remember growing up my dad having them
all the time so i was like oh well that
makes sense so it's definitely
hereditary but i'm sure food and what
you eat and drink also you know play a
role gosh
tell us about the documentary
documentary i'm super excited about this
tell us about it so the documentary team
reached out to me last year around the
time the new york times thing happened
right and i actually had three different
documentary teams reach out to me to
want to do something right super
exciting one of them was from the uk uh
the other two were here and i started
just kind of shooting with everybody i'm
like hey guys yeah sure let's do it and
i'm shooting with them shooting with
them and then it got to a point where it
was like all right
i'm gonna have to make a decision here
because there were there were like
a lot of i guess
how do you say like a conflict of
interest because one documentary team is
like well we want exclusive to your
story and then if you if you're doing
stuff with the other two documentaries
it's going to like dilute what we're
trying to do here and if we if we go to
netflix or we go to hbo max or you know
any one of these places they're going to
want to know if this is an exclusive
story if there's going to be other
documentaries coming out about it as
well right so i had to come to a point
like maybe a month or two into it where
i was like all right like like the
documentaries team reaching out to me
like hey you're going to like which one
you're going to go with and i ultimately
decided to go with the one i'm with now
optimist um
and shout out to chris chris temple he's
uh the director and we've been shooting
every single month since then and
they've just been following me along
they were the ones that came to your
house yeah that was them whatever um i
just felt like he had the same vision
that i had for the story like shedding a
positive light on crypto and on dogecoin
and he had my my best interest at heart
so i went along and you know went with
him and they've been following me along
this journey you know what i mean every
snl they were there they were filming
behind the scenes on the snl you know at
your house when i went to uh meet with
me kevin and we walked around and did
you know our video they were there for
that as well and just every major event
that's happened in the past year
interesting so what they want to do is
film this entire thing and then pitch it
to different networks to see who will
buy it well they've already been in that
process i see so in the very beginning
it's independently funded because they
want to have full creative control of
what they're doing right so if netflix
has a netflix original and they're
paying for it they're going to want it
to go a certain way they have their
people their producers right so this was
independently funded from the beginning
so they have full creative control and
since then they've been pitching the
networks and so
i'm actually i don't think i'm allowed
to say
where they're going to go but they
already have a place that they're going
to have it going to what if we bleep it
out can we bleep it out
um well okay i'll say this i'll say the
two major ones that they're going for
is netflix and hbo max and so they're in
talks with them i don't think they've
actually officially um closed a deal
with either one of them but those are
like the main ones can you say like how
are you making money based off these
off of what the documentary yeah well
you're not allowed to make money well
it's uh
i forgot what it's called but there's a
there's a
there's a
a phrase or something along those lines
where if you if you're doing a
documentary
it's it's it's uh
it's it's frowned upon well you're not
supposed to pay the the main character
of a documentary because then it's like
wait is he acting is this you know what
i mean like if you're doing a
documentary you're not supposed to pay
the actual people in the documentary did
you have a lawyer review the contract
no i haven't i mean i haven't i haven't
like
signed i haven't signed the the the
final official document
but that's impossible that's impossible
that they would have invested that much
of time and resources without you having
signed a document that gives away your
rights well i signed some
so
yeah but but there's nothing lingering
there's
by the time they start filming and
investing in you it's signed there's no
like yeah so backing out you know at the
very end be like no i don't want to do
this anymore so what's the purpose of
doing this documentary if you're not
making money well the purpose is
exposure right it's brand awareness
right so like for me to be on netflix on
hbo max there's awareness brought to my
brand and who i am as a person and then
obviously my youtube benefits from that
my social media accounts benefit from
that so yeah i'll tell you i worry that
uh when you had three you know two or
three different companies all at the
same time like kind of circling you
that was your point to sell the rights
you don't have to get paid necessarily
for the documentary itself but you're
selling the rights to your story and one
of these companies could do that
exclusively i think that's worth
something no for sure it definitely is
well there's a difference too between me
selling my story
like my life story you know what i mean
versus me selling uh what happened to me
in dogecoin you know what i mean like
that's it's a pretty big story
and and i guess it plays a role in my
life story right but it's not like i
haven't sold my exclusive rights to my
life story you know what i mean so
okay but yeah
it's it's uh interesting it's fun yeah
are you excited to not be followed
around like different places like how
many hours per day do you think they're
with you shooting and everything
oh it's it's not like every single day
oh it's a reality tv show no
it's like major events right so when we
went to your house they shot that when
we went to meet kevin they shot that snl
they shot that right so the pokemon
thing we went to yeah remember they were
there for that yeah so they've just kind
of been following me on all the major
you know events within the last year but
my story is kind of intertwined within
the documentary right so
ultimately it's it's more so about the
meme economy and how it went from
gamestop amc to light crypto dogecoin
you know what i'm worried about and and
i think
and i think it was about six to eight
months ago i was uh no it was early in
the year and i really believed that um
that there was something to be said
about the value of a meme
but
i am worried that
just like any sort of cycle that even
though there is value it's only valuable
as long as it is of a meme and as soon
as that interest fades away
can it come back dogecoin has come back
a few times
but i worry that that maybe the meme
wave
has somewhat dissipated that it was big
last year and i think memes are gonna be
gone
the meme investing economy i think
could
could potentially see a bit of a
downtrend
i don't know because it seemed like so
many people were really into it last
year and like that was the trendy thing
and i'm worried that you know even
though there is a value to all of that
attention
how long could you sustain that for and
maybe that could be sustained for a few
months weeks even years but at what
point do you really look back at that
you know 10 years from now
were they able to transition away from
from a meme and into something more
permanent it's definitely going to be a
challenge you know what i mean like i
don't i don't think it's going to be
easy peasy like all of a sudden dogecoin
is going to be used everywhere currency
everywhere and all of a sudden it's a
stable whatever you know what i mean
i feel like it's it's kind of a work in
progress i just really believe like you
said value and memes right i truly
believe there is value in memes there's
there's there's value in going viral
there's there's value in in in being
everywhere right like communicating with
memes right so i don't know how often
you guys send memes to each other but i
send memes to my friends all the time
you know what i mean and it's one of
those things that's kind of how we
communicate and
and with those queen i remember you also
saying
you know the the meme the doge meme like
what if that fades out yeah to me it was
more so a representation of memes in
general and i feel like memes are always
going to be around i don't think like as
far as meme investing or or specifically
like gamestop you know related kind of
things that could have a downtrend i i
completely agree with you um but also a
lot of people were thinking dogecoin was
going to go right back to where it was
you know and and it's like several times
over
more you know prices a lot higher than
that yeah so i feel like it's over time
the next two years the next five years
there's always going to be a place
i feel like for dogecoin because it was
the first original meme coin but first
you want to thank our sponsor ladder so
i just got my first tinder match in
months and even though she hasn't
responded yet seeing my potential future
wife makes me realize just how important
and fragile life is and exactly why it
should be protected a healthy 35 year
old man can get his family a million
dollars in coverage for only 35 dollars
a month a price well paid for such a
financial cushion and if you agree
choose ladder you could waste hours of
your time applying for life insurance in
person and then spend weeks waiting to
see if you're approved or you could use
ladder
with ladder you can get fast and
affordable life insurance all from the
comfort of your own home all you have to
do is sign up from your phone or laptop
and it only takes a few minutes all you
need is a photo or laptop to apply and
ladders smart algorithms will let you
know instantly if you're approved there
are no hidden fees and you can cancel
anytime you want and if you change your
mind in the first 30 days they will give
you a full refund life insurance only
gets more expensive as you age so
there's not a better time to sign up
than now so go to ladderlife.com iced
coffee today to get your free quote
that's l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
iced coffee ladderlife.com iced coffee
thank you so much ladder and back to the
podcast what about floki
i love floki i absolutely love floki and
even though things are down like i said
the whole crypto market is down right
now
i absolutely am bullish on floki and i
feel like they have so many things on
the horizon that the potential is so
incredible like the video game is
probably the biggest one in in my
opinion right so i don't know how well
no you did a video on fellow i did a
video on floki but i haven't followed
them since that video which was probably
four months ago five months ago okay so
valhalla was the biggest thing right
right and and it's a play to earn nft
metaverse video game and
it's basically a game that's going to
come out on the blockchain you'll be
able to actually play in the video game
and make real money in it and be able to
cash out at the end of the day so
essentially
you can have a job playing a video game
and that's already been proven the proof
of concept with uh axia infinity yeah
it's interesting though you mentioned
that because so many um
what was disappointing about floki was
that valhalla didn't come out it didn't
come out at the time where they were at
their peak right and so the interest
it's faded and since then
so many other
um
cryptocurrencies and nfts have been
using the same thing this play-to-earn
business model where you can play and
you could create these nfts and beef
them up it just seems like that's going
to become saturated metaverse is going
to be saturated for sure and a lot of
these games are going to be you know in
in that realm of metaverse
ask uh play to earn ask type of type of
thing you know what i mean so with floki
i feel like floki's probably the
strongest
one in that field when it comes to okay
creating a video game play to earn
metaverse where you have nfts that you
know floki has their own nfts that they
sell as well and they'll be able to
utilize them within the video game so
there are a lot of other coins coming
out with similar metaverse kind of
things and you're right it's going to
get saturated but i feel like the
strongest ones are going to survive at
the end of the day i was told over the
weekend there's this game called i think
it's like cool cats you heard of it no
cool cats cool cats nfts uh
chris from dumb money okay invested over
him or i guess he didn't he invested a
hundred grand but he says now they're
worth about 1.2 million dollars these
these cool cats i cannot make this up
okay nfts yes nfc's cool cats uh in the
game or something you own these entities
and they produce what's called milk
i kid you not these cool cats produce
milk
the milk is redeemable for ethereum that
you could cash out of so like
the longer you hold on to these cool
cats the more milk they make
that you could routine for ethereum to
then say the whole thing i don't get it
so
how much milk do they make he doesn't
know yet he finds out tomorrow i kid you
not what do they start producing milk
100th of an ether yes
showing me these things it's like 90
grand for a unicorn cool cat that's
insane yeah i know he also invested in
uh in crypto punks yes and board apes
and stuff like that correct you know um
without it's funny cause i remember we
had a conversation and he was like i
didn't know too much about it but like i
understood the concept of it right and
so he's made a ton of money on crypto
punks and on board apes and all that
stuff so nfts man i'm i'm
i'm starting to buy into nfcs too
i just realized by the way what you
should have done
if you were down on floki to have sold
floki
yes
use that loss to offset your gain on
dogecoin
you would you would be completely tax
free now on dogecoin
every pretty much everything that you
would make right now would be tax-free
on dogecoin just from tax loss
harvesting because right now
the bill in the buildback better act
they wanted to get rid of crypto tax
loss harvesting okay the buildback
better act right now is kind of held up
in congress so we don't know if it's
going to be passed or not we don't know
what the final form is going to be but
for last year you could have done that
the crazy thing is this they want to tax
you on the gains you make in crypto
right but they're trying to take away
the losses you're not allowed to use
those i've never heard of that to offset
other games yeah it's offset
you're allowed to do that or you're not
allowed you're allowed to do it okay
yeah okay it's just like any other
investment but they want you to have a
wash sale so basically the because right
now you'd be able to sell your floky
yeah use that as a write-off sell your
dogecoin increase your tax basis not pay
any tax on that in the process but right
now you'd be able to just buy right back
into floki right afterwards there's no
30-day rule of waiting okay because it's
considered a property and not a security
or an asset it's it's property okay so i
also i also realized with those coins
um remember we were saying capital gains
tax yeah for me to take it out within a
year i'd have to pay 40 percent correct
i think it's like more like 50 feet yes
because you're in california because i'm
in california correct
which is fine
yes
but
yes well
the answer that would be yes depending
on how much you're cashing out but yeah
you would be showing that you would make
you have two million dollars
yes you are right and then moving to
vegas right i'm moving to vegas anyway
right yeah if i stay here for how long
that
you'd have to talk with the tax attorney
it's a bit of a gray area that if you
make your investments in california and
then you move to let's say texas you
sell everything off uh california could
still claim rights to that tax that was
saved because you made those investments
in california and they could argue that
you only moved to i don't know it seems
to be a gray area
uh some say a year i've seen five years
i think with 401ks and roth iras like 10
years it's it it depends it's a bit of a
gray area so i i don't know exactly i
mean i was i mean yes it would have been
had you sold everything
53 right you would have yeah you would
be paying 37
plus 13.3
plus 3.8
sheesh on the top end of that income
that's insane
so yeah 54 you'd be paying 23
uh it's called the net investment tax
and it's when you have more than a
million dollars a year in income
uh you pay an extra 3.8 percent it's a
sur tax just on top of everything that's
regardless of where you live by the way
it's just that's the irs that's that's
like wait that's a federal yes
oh so your federal income tax is
basically 41 not 37.
no it's 37. if you make over money it's
but it's for investments so
capital gains so i have a long-term
capital gains but it also applies to
short-term capital gains okay so if you
if you have short-term capital gains
you're paying 37 plus right then you
could play for it pay 40 so basically i
picked the worst state
you can make that investment into
dogecoin
yes
but you would still be left over with a
significant amount after that i mean
still a big amount but yes just half of
it's gone so yeah
i mean i'm planning on moving to vegas
anyway you know what i mean i was just
wondering if it would be like a year or
like six months or something like that
that would it would take into effect
where i wouldn't have to pay taxes yeah
so what's interesting to me is that your
original plan was to hold on for one
year capital gains and when is that well
that was the thing so is that april it's
going to be coming up no is that
february february yeah february what
what's the date what's the date on that
february 5th oh wow so it's like
actually february 5th wait are we going
to be posting this on the day
that you bought dogecoin the day after
we're posting this february 6th that's
hilarious so almost
366 days
since you bought dogecoin yeah and if
you guys see my youtube videos i have
the little timer
on the upper left-hand corner where all
every single day it'll be like how many
days i've been holding and it's supposed
to go all the way to 365.
so the reason why i said that though was
because of short-term capital gains tax
versus long-term property so like any
day
after that after february 5th 2022 that
i decided to cash out it automatically
goes down to 50 is it 15 percent
20 20 okay
well you wouldn't pay the 3.8 because
you would be cashing out less than a
million assuming the price stays the
same but then again you know it was
kevin o'leary because i said the exact
same thing and it was kevin o'leary that
told me you should never make your
decisions based on the tap tax
implications okay so and it was hard for
me and even now i still like but the
taxes yeah
taxes
uh he said don't even consider the taxes
that should not that should not be a
part of your decision to not sell an
investment that's an interesting way to
look at it yeah
so i mean i don't want to say say i've
taken his advice on that because i've
certainly considered the tax
implications but uh you know
you would you would look at things
differently if you didn't consider the
tax implications of waiting a full year
for sure is that end in hindsight and
everyone says in hindsight that it ended
up costing you more money than you saved
yeah yeah yeah i mean sometimes i think
about that too i'm like all right
if
let's say i had completely sold out of
dogecoin right the day before snl or
whatever
and made that significant amount of
money
would i still have
the social media presence or the youtube
presence that i have today and i don't
think so i do
i think you would be even i would think
you would have more of a presence now
before we go into that i think it'd be
interesting to see what like had you
sold at the peak versus waited a year
assuming the exact same price okay to
see what the difference would be yeah so
2.8 you'd be left with 1.4 million
dollars left over after tax that's just
cash in your pocket um that would be
we're just rounding off to 50. actually
if we want it to be accurate let's do 53
so if you waited a year and the price
was exactly the same
you would only be saving 445 000 i say
only i want to be more than that no
that's how much you're saving 53 versus
uh what did i say
20 plus 13 3 plus 3 39
39.2 39.2 percent wow okay yeah so
you
and this is easier to explain in
hindsight but of course the 2.8 million
dollars
was kind of held up in limbo because of
445 000. that was the difference between
short and long-term capital gains in
california that's posted about half a
million after tax 440 after taxes
i don't know why it seemed like it was
going to be a lot more no because the
thing you have to consider you're paying
20 to california 3.8 or sorry you're
paying 20 to the irs 3.8 net investment
sur tax plus 13.3
37.1
okay that's it
but that's without no no long-term
capital gains taxes 37
okay versus 53 versus 53 a difference of
15.9 percent okay 15 yeah and you think
people would still watch me after i
cashed out oh yeah i i think
i think they would look at you as a
genius okay as a market timing
investment genius because the thing is
you just need to be right once
that's it and had you sold here's the
thing had you sold you would have gotten
a lot of hate for that first yeah they
would have they would have slaughtered
me online for the first month
but after a month i guarantee 99 of
their opinions will have changed to look
at you like a genius i agree i think the
first month would have been terrible for
you because think about it i was the guy
saying diamond hands how's the guy
saying
on what was the guy saying correct but
no but at the same time even if you did
time it perfectly and you sold and
everything
i don't think that it's good for you to
be seen as like a market genius i don't
think that like like because of the
style of investing like that yeah
because of the style of investing that
you do do and the the appeal for me to
you is that you're real you know what i
mean and when people
start claiming things like oh i'm an
investing genius i'm a marketing genius
and stuff like that then it loses that
personal appeal like you know what i
mean i feel like you know i wouldn't say
that but people probably but you know
what but you know how i knew it was a
good decision um is when how many people
commented even on your video and on our
video at the peak or at when you were at
like 2.2 million how many people say to
sell how many people were happy for you
to have made a life-changing amount of
money and to sell so many people those
people weren't dogecoin holders though
those those people were probably just
finance fans correct right but
to up to appease the dogecoin community
you've essentially spent
1.8 million dollars yeah you you've just
you've basically taken that and just
flushed it down the toilet just to
appease those people on the internet
yeah who were going to comment oh this
is bad why did you why did you i feel
like in a certain way i would also
feel bad because
i i would feel bad to be like hey jack
hold your dogecoin don't sell it and
then i sell it and then jack loses a
bunch of money i'd feel bad like like
for me to do that for me to go ahead and
cash out i would have to make a video
right before and then like hey guys
i'm gonna sell everything so if you're
holding dogecoin right now sell
everything no you you never would tell
people yeah
you just said hey guys no you wouldn't
you people would be if honestly all you
need is a 10 minute video guys made 2.8
million dollars more than i need for my
entire life i don't want to take the
risk sorry i told you to hold no
you could say i didn't expect we would
ever be here my my initial thought was
that it would take over a year to get to
this point it took us three months
i don't want to take the extra risk
um now is the time for me to focus on
other like i'm big into music yeah and
this allows me that to pursue music and
and my passion and thanks to dogecoin i
was able to do this i think yeah some
people are going to be upset at that but
the vast majority of people would look
at that and be like that was a
responsible decision yeah and i think at
the end of the day no one could hate on
that the thing is this yeah at first
everything was all good right i had
people saying oh that's what's up yeah
i'm holding too but and then like as
dogecoin goes down and these people
start you know losing money then it
seems it's like they kind of turn on you
and they get mad at me and stuff like
that and start you know saying negative
comments and things like that and then
when i i'm like all right let me look
into other projects because i'm not
going to be deutsche deutscher my that's
it for the rest of my life so i'm
looking at other projects and i start
looking at floki and stuff people start
turning on me from that and they're like
oh
you're a traitor you're uh you're only
supposed to be about dogecoin over here
talking about floki like why do you love
floki so much like oh is this is this
you know a scheme or something like that
like like i've i've gotten a lot of
negative comments because of that a lot
of hate too because it's like if i'm
looking at other projects or even
cardano when i started buying a cardano
what are you doing well and i'm just
like it's like you can't please everyone
but
i seem to get hate either way yeah i
remember you know what's interesting is
i started getting all of a sudden your
videos recommended again your are they
well our videos that we did together the
iced coffee hour clips of us get
recommended now out of nowhere on the
home page which is weird i watched one
of them and one of them was about me
saying how quickly people can flip
online and they'll love you one day yeah
and then the next day it's just still
completely 180. yeah and once you get
that momentum of just like you know
people get upset
everyone else loves to get upset with
somebody else because it feels like this
this uh your you know camaraderie yeah
exactly we could be in a group together
we all think the exact same way we could
be upset at the same person and share
that experience share that share those
emotions with one another negatively
against somebody else and it switches
how do you deal with it i just accept
that like i don't know i hate to say it
but like every week i'm like
mentally it's like this is last week
i've been doing this for five years now
every week without lasting does this
still affect you uh to a certain extent
yes
but uh
that's why i saved so much it's just
like well last week
i try i mean i really try my best to be
as like neutral as possible to stay in
the middle of things and uh you know
really just to focus on finance i think
i think at the end of the day it's like
personal finance investing it's not a
lot of room for emotion just talk
objectively and the more i talk
objectively the better it is because i
try to i try to respond you know i mean
like i'll see a negative comment and i'm
like no that's not true you know what
i'm trying to like prove my point and
everything and then i get caught in this
whirlwind of like trying to lie
if people are posting negative comments
that you think aren't well founded
realistically whatever reasoning you do
with them is not going to solve it
anyways okay that's just what i've
learned if you see like a really well
written out message that's like very
detailed you can kind of see their point
of view and stuff like that you can
reason with those people but a lot of
the times if they're just like attacking
your like physical appearance or they're
attacking like other random things and
you could tell like based off of like
their wording and stuff like that if
it's not well structured there's no
reasoning with those people i've tried
and that's the other thing too is that
uh and this is interesting with with
kevin going through the same thing as
well with him selling yeah and uh
if his tesla people
everything he sold everything diesel
yeah not just tesla but
when you hold it or you become like an
ambassador let's just say the doge
corner really anything it could be
anything it doesn't have to be ditch
coin it could be water for let's just
let's just say
and you're pushing for water and water's
value is going down and you're pushing
for water and just like people are
losing money with water they they'll get
upset at a certain point like you misled
us yeah even though you know they they
were choosing voluntarily to follow your
advice yeah so
you know sticking with one thing like
that you're going to get
that backlash if it goes down so that's
why i was thinking well at least if if
you cash out
pretty much everyone at that point was
in profit
um it would have been hard to lose money
even if you had sold at the peak
i mean people were buying in at that
price but fewer of them were underwater
or were in the red yeah that makes sense
too that makes sense so it just felt
like the right thing to do man like yeah
like when i was in when i was in the mix
and you know everything was happening it
felt like this is the right thing to do
i should hold this i believe in this
because i do yeah you know truly
genuinely do believe in dogecoin and
this one day will pay off if not today
maybe in a year maybe into
three you know
do you do you have a plan if it doesn't
if it doesn't pay off and if dogecoin
slowly just well that's what it's back
to and it pits back to a penny i i'm
saying i'm thinking this
my
plan would be
one of these other projects that i'm
invested in will do well right so so
even even if though even if my initial
dogecoin buy-in just keeps going down
for whatever reason it never gets to a
dollar
i'm
still heavily invested in other projects
and i'm still hoping that something else
takes off as well
yeah do you feel like sometimes because
it seems like every time you and i talk
you're constantly met with criticism
you're constantly met with people saying
what you're doing is wrong what you
should have done is this it seems like a
lot of people are trying to dictate your
actions and maybe tell you that you made
wrong decisions how do you think that
affects you does it make you more
gung-ho with your positions or do you
think that like like how does that
affect you let's say mentally the thing
is this i'm i feel like i'm generally
very
a very open person right so it's open to
criticism open to hey you should have
done this you should have done that you
have people that are just block off
everything it's whatever i want haters
haters haters and you and even if you're
wrong you can be completely wrong right
i feel like i feel like when i say
something like sometimes i say stuff on
twitter or whatever people like kind of
attack me and i always try to like take
a step back like okay let me look at
what this person said object like
objectively right and see
uh is what they're saying making sense
or not or is this pure hate right and i
always evaluate everything and that's
taxing obviously because you're sitting
there trying to reason everything in
your head but
i feel like i'm a good person i try to
do good you know what i mean i try to
help people and
and it's hard trying to like
almost second guess yourself in a way
like like you're questioning like wait
am i a good person like this person just
said this and this person you know like
and you're really sitting there like
it's like pulling tugging
at your like mental and heart strings
because because it's like you're trying
to always do good things and people
always find a way to find some negative
in it and it makes you second-guess
yourself all the time so it sucks
mentally and
and it takes a toll on you man like i
like never would i have dreamed that one
i'd be in this position
two that it'd be a market it'd be a
place of such it's so polarizing right
yeah crypto like it's not something
that's sound and you know it's way
different crypto investors from stock
investors it's just the communities
alone things go up prices go up you're a
genius you're awesome you're cool thanks
for telling me about that coin you know
what i mean like prices go down you're
an idiot you misled people you're a scam
artist you're
you know what i mean like
it's crazy yeah it's crazy
and what about people constantly telling
you things like you should have sold
because it seems like every time you
come on this podcast it's a very similar
theme where like you should sell you
should sell i'm sure people are always
telling you stuff like that how does
that affect you when people say that you
should have done this what i should have
done yeah i always try to take
everyone's advice and everything
everybody tells me and comments like
with a grain of salt obviously but at
the same time i i see the points that
they're making and some of them are very
valid you know and then you sit here and
you're like wow
i could have three million dollars well
not three million one point whatever
yeah call it one and a half well round
one half versus this and then and then
you know that takes a toll on you too
because it's like but i believed in
something you know what i mean like but
i had conviction but but i want this to
to
to do well and to be the future and it's
like
it it kind of
again second guessing yourself you're
like wait was i right was i wrong maybe
maybe the same person who bought bitcoin
at a thousand bucks saw go up to 17 000
didn't take any profits dropped all the
way back down to 3 000
and just wrote it out and it went to 60
000. and now they're a genius three
years four years later so you see what
i'm saying
a lot of people were called very stupid
when they bought in bitcoin uh and
myself included i started buying bitcoin
at 17
and uh that was like the peak of the
market and i was really curious about
buying it and seeing what the hype was
about yeah i bought in and it helped me
understand now i only invested like 20
grand so i wasn't going all in but it
helped me experiment with what crypto
was and get introduced to the whole
concept even back then like ethereum was
i think at the peak ethereum was like
900 bucks or something like that um and
then it dropped all the way down like a
hundred and something dollars and
everyone with crypto was over it for two
to three years i worry two things one
that that isn't guaranteed to happen
again yeah and i think as the crypto
market gets bigger it's gonna get more
stable and we're gonna see less you know
going from you know a thousand to
seventeen to three to sixty
instead we might get to see like okay i
went from 30 to 70 down to 40 to 80 down
to 50 to you know a little bit more
stable but then i also worry that
in a way your image was so wrapped in
dogecoin that you were the dogecoin guy
without the dogecoin what what was your
brand you were brandless then you were
the dude who sold dogecoin yeah you know
yeah no for sure and and and so okay so
when you bought bitcoin 17 000 you saw
it drop all the way back down to was it
3 000 right did you sell it all so i
sold so
i i don't remember exactly i sold
bitcoin at 17.5 so i wrote it 17 sold
the 17 5 and then i was an idiot and i
basically put it all in different alt
coins
the biggest one i was such an idiot i
bought uh
it used to be ryblocks
rebranded as nano and then now i think
they're coming out with like some other
branding of some sort i i don't really
follow it anymore but i bought nano at
like a doll or something or like a
dollar fifty
and
it went all the way up to i think it was
like forty dollars didn't take any
profits
nope
it fell and fell and fell and it went
back down basically to where i bought it
and at that point i lost everything i
still i still hold it to this day
uh you know i'm not gonna cash out at
this point but uh
yeah yeah i learned the hard way on that
one it's just that's not that's never
something that i'll
deal with again if anything i do
honestly find it pretty admirable that
you did stick to your guns and you you
stayed true to your principles and you
you held like that is pretty impressive
just on a personal level maybe not as an
investor level yeah or you know what i
mean as a financial person but i think
it as a person i think that's and i
honestly hope people see that too you
know what i mean i hope people see that
okay this guy came came out here he did
this thing he said he was gonna hold and
he stuck it all the way out your
integrity is worth more than two million
dollars or whatever maybe you know i
don't know i feel like people i feel
like i hope a lot of people see it that
way as well how are you making money now
because that you quit your job the last
time we spoke yes
so yeah youtube okay i make money on
youtube i also make money selling
merchandise on my website and i also
have started working with a company
actually like a tech team for the past
uh i want to say six months about now
creating
a dose card so it's essentially a visa
card where you can put in dogecoin and
be able to wherever visa is accepted be
able to use your dogecoin and in real
time it'll convert the doge into fiat
and pay the merchant in the amount of
money that the item you want to buy so
i'm creative director over there and
i've been kind of working with them
pretty closely
so yeah
it's it's a bunch of little things i
guess i just don't understand the
converting dogecoin because i just think
if you're gonna sell it you sell it and
then then you don't have to worry about
like i'm to buy this thing and i don't
know where it's trading at the time i
guess it's
it's more of the fun factor you know
it's a novelty card with those coin on
it it's got visa i can use it wherever
visa is accepted i got put i put those
coin in there i use it to buy and then
instead of cash back like a bank card
you get those coin back and it's you
know
you should make a medal
everyone don't no i i do think that
there is actually original i know i'm
saying i think that that actually makes
a difference in the appeal
is metal versus plastic i feel like
we're eventually going to run the course
of metal i know so many people that got
the apple card strictly because it's
metal yeah they don't have everything
the card is metal now
yeah yeah
it's metal sapphire what are the amex
cards of metal after metal what do you
think the next thing is we're going to
go to stone
just regress
no it's funny enough that you say that
though because we are thinking about
coming out with a metal card as well
okay cool like have two versions of it
like you have the basic plan on the dose
card and then you can have a platinum
version of it you know what i mean yeah
but i'm super excited about it i just
want people to be able to use it and
like use those coins to buy whatever i
want and
you know and think about this if i'm in
line we're at target right i'm in line
right in front of you i whip out a card
it's got dogecoin on it right and i'm
buying something that's a conversation
you know what i mean is that is that a
dogecoin card like what you know i think
that's what dogecoin yes i almost think
that we're gonna go back to more so
phone payments
i i think could be a lot more common
yeah i mean how many times i forget my
wallet it's also integrated in apple pay
there we go
it is only a matter of time though for
sure that we have everything on our
phone car keys
plus payment everything yeah which
technically if you have a tesla
is pretty much right the key is the key
is the phone yeah i i've never carried
that actual key on me it's just always
my phone yeah
sorry guys i have this uh i'm hand
holding the camera here but have you
guys seen that they started making
credit cards out of wood
so that they're more eco-friendly it's
like bamboo or something like that
oh you could sell it you could sell the
metal little little metal
strip through it but the rest of the
cars made what i would love
no i haven't i'm just i'm just saying
you know it wouldn't be impossible do
that i would love to see just different
stuff like that just different materials
being used
and uh maybe we go even higher and we
have cars made of like
glass
dropped my credit card and broke it
campaign it just breaks makes a mess on
the phone you need to get a case for the
card
[Laughter]
you know it would be interesting to have
like you could do you could do acrylic
you could do like uh
what vinyl vinyl
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i just use opal as like that that's
the car it's like some rare crystal yeah
moon rock yeah what's that uh material
and phase rugs countertop scram you know
onyx
[Music]
that would be the credit card to get
have you seen uh like they have
meteorite dials on watches and they're
it's the coolest thing ever like
literally out of space yeah it looks
really cool right just the cost of of
creating a card
made out of media right it's got to be
american yeah like that's like tier
three
black card yeah you can buy anything
with that yeah yeah um but yeah tell us
are you comfortable talking more about
your your income sources right now um uh
sure i could tell you guys roughly how
much i make per month yeah okay so
right now obviously it ranges because of
youtube right so i'm making roughly
anywhere from
fifteen to twenty five thousand dollars
a month which is
good right that's a lot money is good
you're mad but you haven't posted in a
month how how no i haven't this month
has been not good
but but before this for example my
biggest month i was may i think i made 9
000 on youtube which was when i'm like
on top of my game you know what i mean
like i'm posting a video like right
today and i'm talking about dogecoin i'm
talking about floki i'm talking about
you know whatever else i'm invested in
um that was i want to say december yeah
so that's you know that's kind of
written over in january or whatever but
i feel like with this year i really want
to like up things to another level you
know what i mean well you said nine
thousand dollars in a month on youtube
youtube but i thought oh so we're
talking okay yeah so 15 to 25 is
everything everything okay
what about uh you know the job i have
sponsorships promotions stuff like that
like i was doing stuff uh i i did i did
a promo for a cereal you know i'm eating
cereal cereal like delicious i love this
cereal it's so tasty guys go get it
that i i did a sponsorship for like
coffee brands um it was a subscription
coffee where like you tried different
types of yeah yeah i think it was trade
coffee yeah
they sponsored me in the good old days
before uh you could go to
bankrollcoffee.com
and vitamins uh
republic i think it's called it's
basically ritual uh malt ritual yeah
ritual see you know yeah they've
sponsored us thank you
so it's the vitamins multivitamins and
i'm sitting i'm like you know guys i uh
i eat a lot of taco bell so to you know
to subsidize all the
vitamins i take this delicious pill but
um it's not delicious but it's good for
you but um that uh what else did i do uh
skillshare
do you worry though that by taking a
month off combined with the market going
down
it it's not going to be the same going
in february
because ad rates are also down across
the board 20 to 25 percent financing
everywhere across the board every single
youtuber i've talked to ad rates are
down significantly more than any of the
this is the biggest drop i've i've ever
seen
across any of the channels in the last
five years so like comparing just
january to last january to january
before yes the biggest single month drop
wow yeah this is the worst january in
years i i had no idea yeah that's crazy
that's crazy i i was just always like
okay as soon as i jump back on the train
you know what i mean like i start
posting every day like i'm gonna be
super like on top of it every single day
we're talking about something and you
know i'll make another nine thousand
others no no i got i gotta tell you man
i'm really worried that you take that
much time off yeah
here's like ruined your channel i've
seen so many and you know some people
say oh yeah you know people could come
back and i've just seen in at least in
finance
everybody that's taking about a month
off your channel is a fraction of what
it used to be wow i've seen this time
and time and time again uh the only
exception i would say
is nato brian the only but but he's a
partial exception because uh he posts so
infrequently anyway and all of his
videos are evergreen so when he posts a
video it's it technically should be
doing well for the next year yeah yeah
it's the only one i've seen
uh that could post once a month
what do okay what is the longest you've
gone without posting a video
five days
max max in the past five years yeah but
maybe the very longest was a week but
that was only because i think my tesla
video took off
and i and i knew if i posted another
video i'm gonna take away from that that
newest video is gonna get the
recommended yeah and not the the tesla
video so i purposely waited for that
tesla video to um settle down wow before
i post another video because i've tested
so many things every time i post a new
video the previous video stops getting
recommended because youtube is more
likely to promote the latest video on a
channel okay and if that latest video
isn't better and you're not 100 etc that
latest video is better than the one
prior to it you're screwed
it's got to be a better video okay yeah
that's why i know like with some of
these videos that i post i've uh like
i've had other videos ready
and the day of i'm like i can't post the
other video because it's not better than
my previous one yeah and it's either i
have to make a video right now that's
better than that or i cannot post and i
make a video that's better
so you have to you still use the other
video or you don't i could post it later
okay cool and it's funny because i
talked to andre about this and i was
like what's the you know what's the
longest you've been without putting out
a video he said
i think he said seven days a week and i
was like in the last three years yes he
said yes yes and like that that that
shocked me because i mean i've been on
youtubers all the time and people go
away for a week or two they go on
vacation whatever come back right like
how do you take vacations like
or you have to pre-plan your content
ahead of time which i'll say is
impossible especially in finance because
there's so many news
yeah you can't post evergreen content
for a week straight
your audience will
not find it interesting because it'll be
like evergreen africa
they want something in there that's
urgent that's news related that's that
is
is for them to that day okay so you
haven't gone on vacation i've gone on
vacation uh five days hawaii but i
worked so hard to pre-plan out videos
specifically for
the time that i was gone around a
holiday where if i didn't post on a
friday it was it was going to not be out
of the ordinary wow okay i honestly
didn't realize like that's how you have
to yeah you have to taking a month off
is basically like
lighting your channel on fire okay
really really really bad and you'll
notice you'll get penalized by youtube
oh so they'll stop running
and here's the thing yes so already
you're penalized by not posting for such
a long time
the only way to recover from that is by
making a video
why i disappeared from youtube and
that's got to be your title you have to
make a video like that addressing where
i've been okay why why did i think why i
left youtube
or why i disappeared from youtube okay
why i stopped posting on youtube like
something like that okay and that's got
it that's a good idea that video has to
be good because you got one chance yeah
that video bombs you're done thumbnail
is you just looking right into the
camera no emotions hands down kind of
sad yeah
and you better be brutally honest with
that video and answer everybody's
comments yeah look through your comments
yeah uh address people and uh you don't
want to make it like an apology but like
explain what's happened to you yeah and
then from there every video after that
has to be perfect like you have no room
for error right you know
okay well i also feel like i have a
little bit of
of some wiggle room in comparison to you
and andre because your videos are so
information based and like well
researched deep dives into whatever it
is that you're looking into and my stuff
is more like fun going you know what i
mean like lifestyle like hey what's up
guys let's talk about that i worry you
have such an audience where they'll
click on your video pause it and just go
to the comments to see what people are
saying yeah yeah and that'll
really hurt your watch time because
you've got a lot of people just watching
clicking not watching the video comments
leave
do you think that's why youtube took
away the ne the down no the thumbs down
thing i don't i don't i'm just people
just check what video oh this has a lot
of you know thumbs down i don't want to
watch the video it's they do have a
point that people do dislike or like
cancel certain creators i think they're
really leaning away from the cancel
culture because they do not want to be
known as the platform that's like
cultivating that sort of thing so i kind
of get it on that sense because you do
see all the time
uh it's interesting when someone will
make like a like an exposed video
everyone will go to the other person's
channel dislike it
okay okay yeah but that creates drama on
youtube and if they're functioning as a
business they would probably want more
drama now because it created it bad for
advertising it's a bad reputation that's
why they got rid of a lot of the prank
channels the drama channel they didn't
want to be known as like you know we're
creating this fostering this community
of drama they want to be a place that
people could go to that that's free of
that yeah that's respectable
um
it's just entertaining and educational
that's that's what i think they want to
be a safe community for everybody and
having these mobs of people being like
oh we're gonna dislike this person and
dislike this yeah that's not healthy i
don't think so i kind of get it from
that aspect but then i also
uh
i also liked being able to see dislikes
on certain certainty videos like if i
want to learn about let's say i want to
learn about blockchain right and i find
a video and i'm hoping this video is
going to teach me everything i want to
know about blockchain but the video is
just terribly done it doesn't explain
anything i'ma sit there for five minutes
and waste my time because at the end of
the video i didn't learn anything i'd
rather know it's dislike ratio right to
be like oh this isn't an informative
video i like it to gauge the sentiment
of the audience on certain topics like
if jeremy let's just say
i'm buying bitcoin and fifty percent of
the people dislike the video i've i've i
asked myself why why did fifty percent
of zotting sound like this audience
different uh what are they investing in
they're not crypto people they're not
crypto but i like to see that gauge and
i i used to look at the like to dislike
ratio in like everyone's videos because
it's it's interesting to see how that
creator is viewed
and when they have a positive like to
dislike ratio it's like okay people like
their content what are they doing right
why are people liking the video i like
to look at that and now i don't get to
see that so it's
do you guys think it'll come back no
i think it'd be nice if they made it
optional for the creator to decide
because wasn't that how it was for a
while no but then they'll single out
every creator who decides to hide their
dislikes why are you hiding why are you
hiding it yeah because then it's like
then it stands out even more like just
show it if you really if it doesn't
matter that much show it yeah uh what i
think they'll do eventually
is right now you could see the dislike
but it doesn't really do anything i
think at some point they'll just remove
it entirely it'll be more like an
instagram more like yeah you don't have
the option to dislike
well like i thought it i thought what
where it helped was was uh the
recommended section right so if a video
gets a lot of likes it gets to the
recommended section versus a lot of
dislikes no i don't think that
necessarily impacts recommendations or
not what's interesting though is they
never had dislikes on comments which i i
wish we could see dislikes and comments
so they basically did the same thing
with comments on videos you i mean that
was never an issue with comments was it
was like oh i can't see my dislikes on
comments i was always curious about that
the only thing i've noticed with
dislikes and comments the most disliked
comments are the ones that show up at
the very bottom yeah
always so at least the disliked comments
get pushed down yeah and then the good
comments correct yeah yeah
yeah there's got to be some sort of
ratio on that yeah that's crazy
so
yeah man
i
i got to get back on the
back on the dose coin what are you going
to post a video
tomorrow morning now
so i'm in vegas i'm going home today
right and then tomorrow morning
i'm gonna wake up and do a video yeah be
careful about this video word see now
i'm like thinking because of what you
said you're like all right well address
it you should you should film it right
here in that seat with that camera that
would be such a good angle wouldn't it
and you could say and if you want to
know more february 6 check out the iced
coffee hour why i left youtube
look at how good that is you look good
you look really good
that's so you guys want to know
something else sure i got botox
no wait
where on my forehead
watch this
isn't that crazy
wait do it again
are you trying to raise your eyebrows
yeah
i didn't even notice yeah well here's
the funny thing my god i went there it's
part of the documentary so i went there
i sat down the surgeon's like
what are you here for you got great skin
yeah and i was like thanks he was like
he's like how old are you i was like 34.
he's like no he's like you're 28 you're
definitely not 30. he's like you have
great skin and then he's like let me
call my skin guy so i guess he's got a
skin guy and then the skin guy comes in
and he's like
how do you think this guy is he was like
oh 27 28 he's like no he's 34 he's like
that's crazy you have great skin and so
i was like thanks and then i got botox
it's true i noticed when you came and
sat down i'm like you have such nice
skin and i think i've noticed that
before but this time especially like
dude it's it's uh it's really clear like
appreciate no what is it like did you
have wrinkles on your forehead before
you guys never gotten anything right no
okay so basically i don't have wrinkles
on my forehead but this is something
they call preventative botox so you get
it done so you don't get wrinkles on
your forehead in the future so it
basically like freezes up the muscles
that would create wrinkles right and
then you don't get it in there
is there a risk to it yeah not good
thumbnails because you can't so
anymore so botox is actually probably
one of the safest procedures there r
there's hardly any risks um i think the
the major risks are if you if you mess
around with it too much so for example
let's say
like he's got he's got elevens right
elevens are the ones that are like this
yeah yeah so let's say i get you know
full full
uh forehead done or whatever of all
botox and the next day i go like this
and i rub my my forehead right it
there's a chance that it could spread if
you're rubbing it while it's still like
taking taking shape and taking place so
that's why the surgeon says you have
seven days where like don't go out in
the sun don't like mess with your
forehead like just let it go to the
right places and then you're good and
then you're supposed to get it at last
it doesn't wear off it does so you're
supposed to get it done every six months
and here's the crazy thing they took two
twins and they tried to botox with both
of them right and so the first twin
no botox at all the second twin got
botox every six months they did this for
10 years at the end of the 10 years one
twin looked significantly younger than
the other one like 10 plus like 15 years
was this something that you were
insecure about before
no it was just something i've always
tried to look into you know just because
like i said i don't have a bunch of
thick lines on my forehead it's just
like i'm afraid in five years i'm gonna
have like crazy here's what you looked
like before because now because you look
normal to me now it's like but i don't
remember because i have the wrinkles i'm
sure you can see like that yeah that and
then i squint a lot and because i squint
yeah this bothers me and it never
bothered me before um and i think it was
about a year ago where i started seeing
myself on camera especially the vlogs
that yeah i hated it and the the lines
like at they crease after all because
sometimes in the sun i'll squint a
little bit like this and and they stay
there for a little bit
and so have you looked into something
for that
so what i started doing is i started
taking uh like a skincare routine that
macy gave me okay and uh so i use uh
retinol cream twice a week and then i've
been moisturizing my face every single
day
um hoping that the moisture
decreases the the wrinkles this would
have to be a procedure gram this would
have to be i don't know if it's botox or
what it is but there's something there
and the crazy thing is this if you get
it before it gets too deep
it almost reverses the the process so so
it's funny i was talking to dylan so
dylan also got botox and he was like man
i was starting to get lines so i went to
get botox and after a while the last
dylan right dylan dylan yeah
yeah yeah so like the lines kind of went
away he got botox yeah he did too we
just
outed him on here i didn't know this is
like a common thing i didn't do
oh it's called brotox sometimes
what because you know it's different all
right i know what we're doing for the
family episode oh my god
but check it out check it out i also i
had no clue i also was thinking about
getting a hair transplant
okay so like i'm starting to see like i
used to have like my hairline was like
perfect and like within the last like
two years it's kind of like gone up a
little bit and i'm like dang man like
you should try start with finasteride
okay that's what i started taking okay
yeah and then and then but the thing is
once you stop taking it doesn't just
everything
so is there another procedure or is
there like it's not a big deal it's it's
one pill every single day
and how long have you been aren't there
side effects to finasteride uh a small
percentage of people have side effects
and i was really really really worried i
was terrified of the side effects
because it's like uh you know well you
could you could just look it up if you
want to decide and you get a small
portion of people claiming they've never
been the same after taking it wow
but uh but yet i've spoken with other
people who have been on it and they say
i don't know anybody else
i've talked to maybe 10 people who were
on it and like ever it seems like
everyone's honest
they don't talk about it but only one
person said they had side effects and
they stopped after a week and then they
were back to normal so i figured you
know i'm going to try it take it very uh
you know day by day
i have not noticed a single difference
at all okay
can you but you can tell the dra the
yeah basically everything just stopped
because yeah my my hair was thinning
have you ever thought about getting a
hair transplant yeah okay
see i uh i've considered taking
something here mine's fine though well
oh jack wait let me see her come on jack
gosh
see i have like the corners but you see
i look at your dad
and your dad has like a perfect head of
hair yeah and so does my mom's dad well
then
but no you can see do you see on the
corners how it's going up and if i grow
what i've noticed is if i grow out my
hair because i generally grow up my hair
very long and i cut it short every time
i grow it long the hair starts to
be heavy because there's like longer
strands of hair and it pulls and then i
feel like i'm balding because i'll feel
up here i'll be like oh my god i'm
balding and then i get a haircut and
then they layer it and stuff like that
and it's not pulling and i'm like oh my
god
so i wouldn't do anything i would say
you're too young to look into that right
now i would say look back at it at like
28 to 32
and consider it that time i'm i'm not
too concerned about it literally every
single time i get a haircut i ask the
hairdresser i'm like am i balding
i swear yeah and every like i will say
one it's so it's so you know what it is
though you know why if i look at you
right now i'm like your hairline's
perfect yeah right i don't know i didn't
know jack six years ago so like so like
you probably look back to when you were
seventeen eighteen straight as i know
you exactly stay with me so you guys
meet me now and you're like you look
fine
but i know what my hairline looked like
eight years ago i'll say look look into
finasteride okay yeah look into that
first uh have you heard of red light
therapy what's up no so it's like these
light these like red lights that they
they kind of you just put it right here
for about 20 minutes and what it does is
it stimulates the blood cells up here so
your hair will grow so it's it's that
and it's a micro needling too kind of
stimulates the okay the blood cells one
thing that's kind of interesting to me
is you decided to get botox for your
forehead but at the same time in my
opinion as a guy i think you'd probably
look a little bit better if you like
maybe
i don't know trimmed or shaved and i
don't know it's like it seems like
you're you're like
but i know you as a friend you wouldn't
be offended that i say that that's why i
feel exactly that's why i feel
comfortable saying that and i wouldn't
be offended if you say something like
that to me but but i feel like if you
were to clean up a little bit the beard
and the hair i think that is like that
would do like tenfold with botox you
would look yes you would look ten years
younger like getting a haircut and
trimming the beard 10 years do you think
go to your length or do you think a
little bit shorter i think yeah like
like shape yeah and i think you may
realize you're not balding if you yeah
what if you do that too my my thought
would be to do a like a slightly shorter
than my hair okay not not long like
jacks slightly shorter than mine yeah
and i would keep some of the beard but
trim it down to like a little bit longer
than what than what jack has yeah uh
just maybe like i think you're weak
you look like dan bilzerian let me uh
i'm gonna show you guys a picture of me
when i had that and you tell and you
guys tell me what you think hold on all
right really quickly uh
jack let me see you there right
yeah but see part of me thinks it's like
wrinkles add like like uh like
personality i i'm cool with my wrinkles
i like the smiling wrinkles this thing
right here my dad has it i'm cool with
it i feel like they're a bigger fish to
fry
no
you look like a model come on
do that again almost
so good dude what my hair used
keep him away from your girlfriend your
wife that's the daughter incredible oh
my god i mean if i was to get a makeover
i'd probably be like that i think you
look so good in that i mean you you're a
good-looking guy clearly so
and in this stat wait let me see i want
to look at the do you have you have you
seen this alex
have you seen it
oh i'm sweating
wait you prefer that or this oh you look
so good for this dude you look like a
bodybuilder yeah oh my gosh
that you need to do that yeah yeah well
i mean i was like look like a like a
male model like i would i would see you
in like zoolander on the cover
the thing is your beard is perfect yeah
i actually uh the haircut i think i
don't mind the long hair on top swooping
it over you're getting a call from
inglewood by the way i don't i don't
mind the hair swooped over yeah dude
come on why wouldn't when was that
picture taken uh
two years ago
yeah i think you were gorgeous man
thanks jack
why did you decide to grow out the hair
um i grew the hair out just because i
was like
i don't know man
i can't even come up with a reason i was
just like i'm just gonna grow it out
like okay here's the funny thing so that
very first video i've ever did on my
dogecoin channel my hair's a lot shorter
i don't know if you guys remember but
like my beard wasn't that long either
the year before that i shaved my whole
head off
and i shaved everything and then i just
started i was gonna grow it all out
evenly because my hair's always been
short here how you saw it right short
hair and long on the top and i was like
let me just grow it out evenly and then
see what i want to do with it and i just
kind of grew it out dogecoin thing
happened and i was like
i'ma just
keep it going it kind of fits with the
thing it does
it's true
it's true but you know what it would
have been funny had you sold dogecoin at
2.8 and then like the next week
seriously and then you show up like hey
guys hello salutations yeah
the rolls royce in the background like
sipping champagne that's hilarious i
mean i like the idea i have to really
think about it though what's their let's
think about it now
what's
supercars would take probably 20. i got
my ear cut at supercuz before there's a
place it's called great clips great
bleeding great clips down the street
it's five minutes away it's where i get
my haircut ten dollars you guys go to
great clips for 15. yeah it's 15
haircuts jack gets his hair cut there i
get my hair cut there
alec got his haircut there who do you
ask for i don't know it's just whoever's
different person every time yeah it's
interesting at great clips they they
have a log of what they've done to your
hair every time you're there and so i
did a new person and they logged into
the community oh graham okay so we see
we used a three
the last time last one yeah we do like
you did a three on the last one and then
we did like uh you know uh we cut your
hair on the top with the scissors uh
this length do you do you want the same
thing yep all right let me put that in
the computer here uh okay perfect she
got me the exact same haircut that's
hilarious that's been the same
experience yeah
yeah okay
i just asked like what do you think
would look good and go ahead and do it
that's what i say yeah
jack got a haircut last time i liked i
like this haircut a lot your hair is
cool yeah thank you i like your hair
thank you i actually like your hair too
to be honest i think it's kind of like
my curls
yeah i like it i think it's cool
when you do that it makes it a little i
don't know questionable but
no that's funny that's what's up man i'm
excited for vegas though i'm super yeah
it's gonna be good to see you around
like great clips closes at 7 p.m
seven in two hours you have time to get
your hair cut before even leaving and
then all you have to do is trim the
beard
no pressure though it's just a stranger
touching my ears really well just
doesn't seem like that's something that
you'd be particular what well if i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it right you
know it's nothing listen hair is hair
it's gonna it's gonna grow back i'm not
particular about mine
it's it's you're like you don't want to
let a stranger touch your hair but you
let a stranger inject you with botox
that's
he was a needle he was a surgeon he
owned the company okay yeah yeah and and
they're
professional hairdressers like they had
their license hung up there that's all
they do all day is give haircuts you've
never gotten a bad haircut there no i
have not
and i and i've gotten bad haircuts
before and you know funny enough the
worst haircut i ever got was from a i
paid this guy like 120 in beverly hills
to cut my hair more than 20 120 to get
my hair in beverly hills it was the
worst haircut i've ever got i hated it
did they buzzed you or no he didn't buzz
it he just gave me a face he just gave
me a crappy haircut
absolutely the worst card i've ever
gotten it was from that guy uh i did
because i felt bad i never went back to
him afterwards you got a bad haircut at
the great cliffs please i've gotten a
bad haircut uh fantastic sam's is what
is the name not a great clips uh
uh probably not i don't know the one
haircut the one here is good i've been
to great clips back in my hometown and i
went to like supercuts great clips like
something yeah i've i've been a super
cuts in great clips before and it's just
like always a bad no it's not always bad
cut it's just occasionally you'll not
get a great cut but it's like 15 and for
the most part it's good good haircuts
and if they give you a bad cut you can
always fix it it's not like it's you
know making or breaking your your style
yes you're putting way too much thought
into this yeah i'm telling you man for
your brand and you can choose not to
listen to us
i'm telling you this will do wonders for
your engagement your audience will not
view you the same
dogecoin is down this is a chance for
you to reinvent yourself it's a new year
you took a month off
this helps explain why i've been gone to
see such a
transformation between
uh you know november and january
gosh i've i've pulled i
what i have not
posted this year i just i know that's
what i'm cause my last video was
right before the new year's yeah so i'm
down because i was thinking did i post
new year's no i posted like a video or
two right before the new year's i was
still on my mom's house i just got
covered the day after yeah so that means
yeah this would be my very first video
this is a good time to reinvent yourself
it's because you only got one shot at
this one because if you like start
posting normal videos then like you get
a makeover yeah
it has less of an effect you started you
just got to start it off fresh okay so
i'm telling you man how about this i'll
pay for your haircut
not not the tip no tax no tip i'll give
you 15 towards the haircut
[Music]
we tried i feel like this is gonna be
the same thing as getting you to sell
dogecoin it's like getting a haircut
getting it on the same level it's on the
same level as that we're not gonna we'll
get kevin on here and kevin's like you
gotta get a haircut man how about how
about you just get half a haircut
just cut it halfway
you know what kevin that makes sense
that makes sense you're really good at
explaining that not gonna do it but
that's not gonna do it but it's a
haircut for those who don't get the joke
kevin's advice was to sell half the doge
going to keep the other half
you guys will like the beer though no
i don't know i mean i think it looks
cool you've never seen me without it
that's what it would you've never seen
me without it no i haven't i think it
looks even know what my jawline looks
like no but we've seen it in the picture
i think it's a cool look like if i was
creating someone in like skyrim i think
i think
i would
i would definitely compliment you yes i
think it's cool like i would definitely
deck them out like that like that's like
level that's a great sound clip you know
what you're keeping some of the skyrim
yeah i think it looks cool it's a sweet
look i think it's radical yeah graham's
like it's not sweet yeah he's never to
come back now
i look like i'm from skyrim no damn if i
were making someone minecraft they'd
look just like
you can't make people in minecraft all
right whatever
jack's like
if
infinity then
next level you were a cool cat i think
it's a rad look i actually the hair and
the beard the length together
all right
you guys are awesome man come on thank
you i can't wait to be out here i'm
moving officially
next month and so my very first uh day
in las vegas will be march 1st so i'll
be around cool it'll be fun gotta play
more ping pong
yeah i gotta get better where are you
moving
um is i'm like by the airport but also
like by like halfway halfway from andre
to the airport got it so i want to move
in with jack you want a room
i mean
what's up what's up
okay so the only issue is i need to
check with other people yeah but i do
have two rooms available oh two i have
two rooms available yes okay i have to
check because i have someone gavin who
kind of wants to move in and then i have
george and george's editor that wants to
move in so three people that want to
move with two rooms available okay but
i'm i'll check with them i'm still down
okay well i mean why don't we play ping
pong too for the room
deal you'll have to take it up with them
a deal no that's not my subject we were
playing ping pong he's really good i'm
jack i'm not good at
i'm good at soccer though so if you guys
ever want to play soccer indoor soccer
team join the league with me let's do it
i'm i'm all about it i'm really good at
talking i'm brazilian i have to be good
at soccer if i'm not good at soccer then
you know
i'm like banished from brazil
deal okay
all right what you want to join no
you're not good at soccer graham no
never play with that said you guys
make sure to visit bankrollcoffee.com
uh how about you ever play sports i'm
just curious like what are you okay no
never played sports graham would be good
at rock climbing
that's not a sport
well
well
badminton
yeah i know i'm just i'm not a not okay
into sports
no i never got into it i'm down for the
soccer indoor soccer league indoor
soccer all right let's do it yeah spring
league serious i'm sure how much is it
i'll give you the money i don't know how
much it is i was gonna do it in the
winter but then the team didn't work out
how about this let's end off with this
okay give us some predictions for
dogecoin over the next year okay we'll
be able to look back at this in here
from now just whatever you think okay
um
i'm trying to be conservative here
no i think dogecoin uh next year at this
time will be
in around 40 50 cents
i feel like that's reasonable what is
that based on um based on robin hood
wall that's based on uh the elon musk um
rocket based on mass adoption
based on um the visa credit card i'm
coming out with based on
i don't know just i feel like it'll
it'll slowly build up
okay
we shall see
anything else jack
i think i'm good what do you guys what
do you guys think bitcoin will be in
here
oh man i i would say
man i i would say anywhere between 20
and 100 grand i i don't think it's gonna
that just yeah that's like literally
everything you can't say
between a penny and a one dollar
answer though his prediction for late
january of 2023
bitcoin will be at sixty thousand
dollars that's a great prediction yeah
if we're just guessing it's it's like
it's not guessing a random guess
educated guessing that's
i don't know
i don't wanna i don't wanna give a price
because it could go down it could go up
i'm just uh a year from so much gonna
happen in a year you guys both have
bitcoin and ethereum yes yeah nothing
else
i got a little bit of doge
yeah you know what i still i still have
the dogecoin that i
bought a while ago for that like button
challenge i think i i put 10k into into
dogecoins down to like four
oh okay
you want to sign funny i did the math on
on how much i put down yeah and i put in
250 000 in a dodge coin at 4.5 cents
right if i had to put 250 000 in a
dogecoin three four months prior or five
months prior october of 2020 it was
two tenths of a penny yeah that would
have been 125 million doge coins which
would have been at this price point at
13 cents 15 million dollars at an
all-time high of 75 cents that would
have been a hundred
million dollars oh but you can't still
do you can't say that oh yeah i just
want to look at it yeah everyone
everyone's like oh if i invested in
bitcoin when it was a dollar and i
invested a thousand dollars in that yeah
it's just a silly thing to do
is this what you spend time thinking
it's like late at night
like if i bought
this that's exactly what i do before i
go to sleep and i look at the chair be
like okay
i'm so sad
you're like at the beach
that's me oh god
thank you so much for watching we'll
link to your info down below in the
description
you'll have to check out your channel to
see if whether or not you've got the
makeover the dogecoin millionaire i'm
not uh i'm not gonna hold my breath
we'll see
we'll see what happens uh make sure to
subscribe hit the like button feel free
to get a free stock down below in the
description center for public bankroll
coffee uh we got the mentorship group as
well if you want to come chat with jack
and i uh basically every week every week
come hang with us for an hour on zoom
every week jacko's live one week i'm
live the other week if you want to be a
part of it i'll link to that down below
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
thank you bro that was that was great
i'm glad you're able to make it was fun
that was so much fun i really wanna get
some thumbnails